Bruce Pearl joins us Continental Tire
Coach's Corner Continental Tire proud to
be the exclusive tire the Dan Patrick
show no matter where you drive what you
drive continental as a tire for you the
Auburn head coach Bruce Pearl how are
you today I'm good I'm good I'm tired
we're still playing wish I was still in
Minneapolis but we're blessed how are
you I'm good I I had no problem with the
call on guy it was the double dribble
that everybody missed I'm curious in the
moment did you see that because I didn't
see anybody arguing or being upset with
a double dribble on Jerome yeah I didn't
see it either you know Bryce Brown was
pressuring and contain the ball and we
knew we wanted to try to get a foul
because we had two to give and gosh when
I saw the disruption in the play I
assumed that Bryce must have deflected
it but obviously tied to Rome just lost
it picked it up dribbled it again and at
that point I was just glad I hadn't got
a shot off I was glad we executed the
foul and we were you know 1.5 seconds
closer to advancing classy of you after
the game you didn't rip the officials
but how tough was it fortunately there
was a long walk from the court to the
microphone you know and and and and your
first reaction is you know obviously
what my first reaction was like you got
to be blanking kidding me and but I
think at some point pretty quickly I
recognized that I had a responsibility
as a leader as a coach as a as a teacher
as a father to do the right thing in
that situation and make sure my planners
understood it was right they could I
promise you Dan what I'm doing right now
is I'm sitting and thinking about I did
not have a great offensive game plan I
didn't do a very good job of taking
advantage of their high ball screen
hedges you know there were some things
that I could have done better that that
are haunting me a little bit the last
couple of nights of sleepless nights
personally not
last call you worried about what you can
control you do you don't worry about
what you can't control
and I can't yeah I must speaking of
control what play did you think Auburn
was going to run on the play that guy
got her Virginia when he got found oh my
gosh Dan I took an easel the board and I
drew a line from the inbound pass it to
that corner to that corner and I wasn't
is one line is back and forth back and
forth back and forth I could this is
where the balls going so I took Austin
Wiley who is my biggest player with my
longest Winstead and I put him on the
ball but angle to that corner but but
because of the way the floor is built
and there's much more room on the
sidelines the embalm passer was ever
stepped back further and actually have a
passing lane through that corner kind of
very much like at Vanderbilt and I
actually got beat at that about the very
same way and so the way the core was
built may be advantage to throw the ball
there now they did a good job of faking
a lob and slipping the shooter to the
corner and my my call for my defense was
to switch everything to switch out and
switch everything we did not we stayed
attached and as a result of staying
attached we challenged Lake yeah I was
wondering you know guy hit the big
three-pointer from the other corner and
I didn't know if you were gonna try to
take him I know they have other weapons
but I didn't know if you were just gonna
say guy is not going to be the guy who
beats us no pun intended right well what
they did on that plate and the other two
plays they're very similar they back
screened in with two bigs so in other
words in that back screen if you're
switching it's going to take up one of
your bigs and force that big to go out
on on a challenge and and and instead we
stayed connected which is what we have
been doing and and so similar doubt he
is our best on-ball defender challenge
and aside it's got great legs and he's
slippery he's hard to scream but but
listen and you're making these questions
are making a great point Virginia did
make those to place you know we had made
unluck we made a 14-0 run in the last
five four minutes of that game
get to point Li but we also didn't do we
missed a free throw they made of three
we filed a three we made three mistakes
they made three place and that's how
they get and that's why they're still
there and and you got up you got to take
your hat off to them that does not take
much away from all birds historic rather
the Final Four a road traveled that was
as challenging as any ever to get to the
Final Four and and and put our
basketball program and our university on
the map I'm on a damn Patrick show on
Monday morning of the Final Four
okay you talk about arriving please you
gonna watch the game tonight
I think so well wait what's that mean
you either are you're not if it's on and
you walk by you go Oh what what's on I
might not watch it because it's because
it might be just painted I want you know
I'm very very happy for Tony and for
Kristen for their programs but I don't
know because because I'm I just it's not
necessary gonna be productive and it
won't be entertaining talking to Bruce
Pearl Harbor and head coach joining his
Continental Tire Coaches Corner
main cabin Masters is on at the same
time very relaxing soothing you could
probably million dollar listings Los
Angeles there's other shows to watch
that I might recommend you know I might
take my wife out to dinner and and we
might celebrate our season and I may
just not even watch television tonight
how's that did you realize what she goes
through they had the camera on her I you
know can you at least can help control
what the outcomes she was just there on
the sidelines and you could just see you
know she was an emotional wreck with
that yeah okay my coverage didn't it oh
my god I went wait is that that that's
pearls voice I'm telling you that's why
there's hope for everybody if a girl
like me can be in the Final Four another
beautiful life like that I'm telling you
there's hope you know
the greatest things about doing this and
doing this is is you think about your
life's greatest experiences whether it
be the birth of a child or special
moments you share that with your with
your closest friends and your family and
so the road in a final for this run
we've shared them with your my son is on
my staff I love my coaches for
tolerating me because you know because I
can be a demanding boss and then as far
as your family is concerned you're right
you put them through all that emotion
and and you know but guess what at the
end of the day you still bringing home a
decent check a lot better than what I
brought on when I was in Division two or
assistant for 14 years and so you know
you know sure now that that might help
ease the pain who wins tonight I think
Texas Tech is the better team because
they're deeper I think the way Texas
Tech guards and how they switch out on a
lot of different things they've got a
lot of different parts I think hunter is
kind of a big game for them they're
virginia's inside kids need of a big
game for them because Texas Tech will
switch out on their shooters and make it
difficult for those kids to catch and
shoot Virginia leading Purdue they way
they did in a miracle beating us the way
they did and another miracle you know if
you believe you know if you believe
things you know like happen in threes
then you know that maybe Virginia's you
know going to finish the job and this
entire run but Texas Tech I think is the
better team I could just see the
headlines in Virginia pearl sour grapes
picks Texas Tech to breathe Virginia
well listen you know what that's right
seriously for one second that's why you
ever you have a job to do your job is to
entertain and make people laugh but your
your job is to try and get it right I
know you there's one thing to have an
opinion but it's another thing sometimes
when in in the news things get reported
so falsely because you know what people
listen to you and they believe what they
hear sometimes they believe what they
read and that's why I appreciate you and
the job that you've got you've always
done because you get it there but you've
always been able to make me laugh but
you but you've always you know you're
you're accurate I know you try to be
accurate so I appreciate that
Thank You coach enjoy the offseason and
we'll talk to you soon okay look forward
to it Darren thank you that's Bruce
Pearl Auburn head coach Continental Tire
of Coaches Corner for more Dan Patrick
show to the audience channel 239 on
DirecTV or download the Dan Patrick show
app
[Music]